WE BEGIN OUR BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
>>> TONIGHT, IT APPEARS ANOTHER
SO-CALLED RUSSIAN BOMBSHELL HAS
FALLEN COMPLETELY FLAT.
THE GUARDIAN TODAY REPORTED
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE THAT FORMER
TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER, PAUL
MANAFORT AND WIKILEAKS FOUNDER,
JULIAN ASSANGE MET MULTIPLE
BETWEEN 2013 AND 2016 AT THE
ECUADORIAN EMBASSY IN LONDON.
PAUL MANAFORT IS STRONGLY
DENYING ALL OF THAT FIRING BACK
IN A POWERFUL STATEMENT THAT
READS, THIS STORY IS TOTALLY
FALSE, DELIBERATELY LIBELLOUS.
I HAVE NEVER MET JULIAN ASSANGE
OR ANYONE CONNECTED TO HIM.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN CONTACTED BY
ANYONE CONNECTED TO WIKILEAKS
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY.
I HAVE NEVER REACHED OUT TO
ASSANGE OR WIKILEAKS ON ANY
MATTER.
MANAFORT IS VOWING TO PURSUE ALL
LEGAL OPTIONS AGAINST THAT
PAPER.
WIKILEAKS ARE GOING FURTHER
TONIGHT.
THEY TWEETED, QUOTE, WILLING TO
BET "THE GUARDIAN" $1 MILLION
AND ITS EDITOR'S HEAD THAT
MANAFORT NEVER MET ASSANGE.
ASSANGE TOO RIGHTLY SO MOVING
AHEAD ON POSSIBLE LEGAL ACTION
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABSOLUTELY
REBUFFED BY BOTH PARTIES
INVOLVED, WHAT'S FASCINATING IS
"THE GUARDIAN'S" SORRY FILLED
WITH SERIOUS FLAWS AND NO
MEETINGS AND NONE ON THE RECORD.
THE ECUADORIAN EMBASSY IN LONDON
IS ONE OF THE MOST SURVEILLED
AND SECURED BUILDINGS IN THE
WORLD.
I KNOW.
I WENT THERE.
I INTERVIEWED JULIAN ASSANGE IN
JANUARY OF 2017.
VISITORS ARE MONITORED,
PHOTOGRAPHED, VIDEOTAPED BY
MULTIPLE GOVERNMENTS.
NOW, "THE GUARDIAN" IS BEING
ACCUSED OF QUIETLY STEALTH
EDITING THE STORY.
THE PAPER ALTERED THEIR OWN
HEADLINES ADDING WORDS SOURCES
SAY.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT IN
BEGINNING AND THEY SOFTENED KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE LANGUAGE HOURS
AFTER RECEIVING THE BACKLASH.
SHE JUMP ON ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING RUSSIA EXCEPT FOR
HILLARY'S PHONEY DOSSIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD SHARP WORDS
FOR ROBERT MUELLER.
THE PHONEY WITCH HUNT CONTINUES
BUT MUELLER AND HIS GANG OF
ANGRY DEMOCRATS ARE ONLY LOOKING
AT ONE SIDE, NOT THE OTHER.
WAIT UNTIL IT COMES OUT HOW
HORRIBLY AND VICIOUSLY THEY ARE
TREATING PEOPLE, LYING FOR THEM
REFUSING TO LIE.
MUELLER IS A CONFLICTED
PROSECUTOR GONE ROGUE.
TRUMP CONTINUED, THE FAKE NEWS
MEDIA BUILDS BOB MUELLER UP AS A
SAINT WHEN IN ACTUALITY, HE IS
THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
HE IS DOING TREMENDOUS DAMAGE TO
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
WHERE HE IS ONLY LOOKING AT ONE
SIDE, NOT THE OTHER.
LOOK AT THEIR PAST AND WHERE
THEY COME FROM.
LOOK AT THIS, $30 MILLION.
THE PITCH HUNT CONTINUES.
THEY HAVE NOTHING BUT RUINED
LIVES.
WHERE IS THE SERVER?
MEANING HILLARY'S SERVER.
LET THESE TERRIBLE PEOPLE GO
BACK TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
STILL, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
LETTING THE PROCESS PLAY OUT.
HE TOLD "THE WASHINGTON POST"
TONIGHT HE HAS NO INTENTION OF
STOPPING THE INVESTIGATION.
THE PRESIDENT'S CONCERNS ARE
BEING ECHOED BY LEGAL SCHOLARS
LIKE ALAN DERSHOWITZ, WHO WARNED
TODAY ABOUT WHAT MUELLER'S TRUE
MOTIVES REALLY ARE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> MUELLER IS NOT GOING TO
PRODUCE A NEUTRAL REPORT.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BE FAIR.
HE IS GOING TO PRODUCE WHAT HE
BELIEVES IS GOING TO BE A
DEVASTATING ATTACK.
HE IS GOING TO PUT TOGETHER
EVERYTHING.
HE IS GOING TO USE INFORMATION
FROM MANAFORT AND OTHERS WITHOUT
NECESSARILY DISCLOSING THAT
THERE THEY ARE LIARS.
THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM HAS TO BE
READY.
>> THIS IS WHAT I HAVE BEEN
SAYING FROM THE GET-GO.
THE CLASSIC MUELLER, ANDREW
WEISSMAN, PITBULL TACTICS, USING
THREATS, COERCION TO GET PEOPLE
TO WHAT WE CALL TEST THE LIE.
IN OTHER WORDS, TELL US WHAT WE
WANT TO HEAR.
WE ARE GOING TO GO EASY ON YOU.
IF YOU DON'T TELL US WHAT WE
WANT TO HEAR, YOU MIGHT SPEND
THE REST OF YOUR LIFE IN JAIL.
LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THIS IS FASCINATING.
PAUL MANAFORT AND JEROME CORSI,
THEY ARE NOW TAKING A STAND,
REFUSING TO COOPERATE AND GO
ALONG WITH THE TEST THE LIE
SCHEME.
THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO TELL A
STORY THAT THEY WANT TOLD.
EVEN BOTH OF THEM, ELDERLY MEN,
RISKING LIFE IN PRISON.
THEY COULD SAY EXACTLY WHAT
THESE ROGUE PROSECUTORS WANT TO
SAVE THEMSELVES.
CLEARLY, THEIR CONSCIOUS REFUSES
TO ALLOW THEM TO LIE.
CNN REPORTING THAT ROBERT
MUELLER HAS HIS HANDS ON 2016
E-MAIL COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
CORSI AND ROGER STONE,
SUPPOSEDLY SHOWING SOME ATTEMPT
FROM STONE TO SEEK INFORMATION
FROM WIKILEAKS.
WE'LL SEE HOW THIS PLAYS OUT AS
MUELLER CONTINUES TO TURN THE
SCREWS ON BOTH CORSI AND STONE.
ONE THING AS I HAVE READ IT, IT
DOESN'T SHOW THAT THEY KNEW
ANYTHING WAS STOLEN IN ANY WAY
BY ANYBODY.
ANYONE EVER HEAR OF THE PENTAGON
PAPERS?
JUST A THOUGHT.
REMEMBER, IT IS NOW DAY 559 OF
MUELLER'S DESTROY TRUMP WITCH
HUNT.
ZERO EVIDENCE, ZERO, OF
TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION.
WE HAVE LYING TO THE FBI, LYING
TO PROSECUTORS, LYING ON LOAN
APPLICATIONS, DIDN'T PAY YOUR
TAXES.
WHERE IS THE COLLUSION?
WHY NOT GO AFTER HILLARY?
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS A
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM?
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR PHONEY
RUSSIAN LIES THAT WERE FED TO
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, TO
INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION AND
NO LEGAL CONSEQUENCES?
PRESIDENT TRUMP, EVERYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH HIM, THEY TURN
THE SCREWS EVER SO TIGHT.
MUELLER AND HIS MERRY BAND OF
PARTISAN INVESTIGATORS WITH A
HORRIFIC TRACK RECORD.
IT IS A TRAVESTY OF JUSTICE, THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION SCANDAL WE HAVE HAD.
NEVER MIND HILLARY CLINTON FROM
THE GET-GO GOT EXONERATED, NO
REAL INVESTIGATION.
THEY WERE WRITING HER
EXONERATION IN MAY AND THEY
DIDN'T INTERVIEW HER AND 17
OTHER PEOPLE UNTIL JULY.
SHE COMMITTED OBVIOUS AND CLEAR
FELONIES INCLUDING OBSTRUCTION
WHEN SHE DELETED, ACID WATCHED
AND YOU BUSTED UP DEVICES.
THE FRIENDS IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, THEY CAN'T GET ENOUGH.
THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT THE DUAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
COMPLETELY OBSESSED WITH A
PHONEY TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION
THEORY.
THEY ARE ALL BUT IGNORING THE
MAJOR SCANDAL SURROUNDING WHAT
MIGHT BE THE WORLD'S SKETCHEST,
SO-CALLED CHARITY.
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION BACK IN
THE NEWS.
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION NOW
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY INTO BILL
AND HILLARY'S SURPRISE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION.
FBI ALTHS ARE SEEKING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
EMPLOYED AN ELICIT PLAY TO PAY
SCHEME FOR YEARS.
REMEMBER, DURING HILLARY'S
TENURE AS THEN SENATOR AND THEN
SECRETARY OF STATE AND DURING
HER TWO RUNS FOR THE PRESIDENCY,
THAT FOUNDATION RAKED IN TENS
AND TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
MANY OF THE LARGEST DONATIONS
COMING FROM FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM AUSTRALIA, NORWAY,
THE NETHERLANDS, IRELAND, AND
REMEMBER, HILLARY CLINTON'S XLAM
TO BE THE CHAMPION OF WOMEN
DURING THE 2017 CAMPAIGN, HER
FOUNDATION TOOK IN TENS AND TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
COUNTRIES WITH THE MOST
DESPICABLE, DISGUSTING, HORRIFIC
HUMAN RIGHTS RECORDS, TREATING
WOMEN LIKE SECOND AND
THIRD-CLASS CITIZENS AND WORSE.
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION TAKING
BETWEEN $10 MILLION AND $5
MILLION FROM SAUDI ARABIA TO
FORBID WOMEN FROM TRAVELING
WITHOUT A MALE GUARDIAN'S
PERMISSION, PERSECUTES
CHRISTIANS AND JU
CHRISTIANS AND JEWS AND GIVES
THE DEATH PENALTY TO GAYS AND
LESBIANS.
THEY TOOK MILLIONS FROM THESE
COUNTRIES AND BOUGHT THE CLINTON
SILENCE AND THEY TOOK MORE FROM
QATAR AND UAE AND ALGERIA.
SHE NEVER CRITICIZED THOSE
ATROCIOUS HUMAN RIGHTS RECORDS
LIKE WE HAVE REGULARLY.
IN 2016, THE FOUNDATION TOOK IN
A WHOPPING, GET THIS, THE YEAR
SHE IS RUNNING, $62 MILLION.
IN 2017, AFTER CLINTON'S
DEVASTATING LOSS TO DONALD
TRUMP, HER FOUNDATION ONLY
RECEIVED $26 MILLION IN
DONATIONS.
THAT'S A HUGE, MASSIVE DROP.
AFTER IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WOULD NEVER BE
PRESIDENT, SO WHAT WERE ALL
THOSE BIG DONORS HOPING TO GAIN
FROM THEIR ENORMOUS DEPOSITS
INTO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION?
LOOKS TO ME LIKE THAT'S CALLED
ACCESS, PAY TO PLAY, PAID ACCESS
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND DONALD
TRUMP EVER DID THIS.
YOU ARE BUYING ACCESS THAT NO
OTHER LAW-ABIDE BE CITIZEN WOULD
EVER DREAM OF.
DO YOU THINK THEY GET
INVITATIONS TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
ACCESS TO THE PRESIDENT IF SHE
HAD WON, ACCESS TO THE SENATE
SEAT WHEN SHE HAD THAT, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WHEN SHE WAS
SECRETARY OF STATE?
IF EVERYTHING WENT ACCORDING TO
PLAN, ACCESS TO THE OVAL OFFICE.
EVERYTHING DIDN'T GO ACCORDING
TO PLAN AND HILLARY CLINTON LOST
BECAUSE YOU, WE, THE PEOPLE
VOTED AND DONALD TRUMP BECAME
PRESIDENT IN SPITE OF ALL THE
DEEP STATE'S EFFORT TO PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENING.
THEY ARE DELEGITIMIZING AND WE
WILL SEE IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS
NOTHING BUT AN ALL-OUT EFFORT
AND ASSAULT TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENCY OF DONALD TRUMP.
NOW, WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UNCOVER WHAT LOOKS LIKE A
COMPLETELY CORRUPT PAY TO PLAY
SCHEME THAT SHOULD HAVE NO PLACE
IN THIS CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC
OF OURS.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THEY
CHOOSE TO IGNORE THIS DEVELOPING
SCANDAL.
THEY ARE ALL THINGS DEMOCRATIC
AND THEY ARE AN EXTENSION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE TOO BUSY COVERING
STORMY AND ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
THEY DON'T WANT TO COVER THE
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
NOT IN A FAIR AND HONEST WAY.
NOW, THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS HAVE
ARRIVED SOUTH OF SAN DIEGO.
THE BIASED PRESS CAN NO LONGER
IGNORE THE SERIOUS SITUATION OR
PRETEND IT IS SOME GRAND
CONSPIRACY THEORY COOKED UP BY
THE GOP TO GET VOTES IN THE MID
TERMS.
INSTEAD, THE MEDIA'S ECHO
CHAMBER IS SPINNING OUT OF
CONTROL OVER THE USE OF
NON-LETHAL TEAR GAS.
MANY ASSAULTING OUR OWN BORDER
PATROL WITH ROCKS AND BOTTLES
AND OTHER PROJECTILES.
WE HAVE IT ON TAPE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>>> BAD THINGS BREAKING OUT AT
THE SAN YSIDRO PORT OF ENTRY
NEAR TIJUANA.
THE PRESIDENT FALSELY DESCRIBED
IT AS AN INVASION.
NOW, HE SEEMS INTENT ON TRYING
TO MAKE IT AS UGLY AS HE
IMAGINED IT.
>> IS THERE ANY DEFENSE FOR
USING TEAR GAS ON CHILDREN?
>> WHAT AMERICANS REALLY SHOULD
BE, SPECIALLY TRUMP SUPPORTERS,
PEOPLE WHO DON'T QUITE SEE THE
INHUMANITY THAT'S GOING ON HERE,
WHO MAYBE THINK THAT 3-YEAR-OLDS
NEED TEAR GAS.
>> THERE HAS TO BE A PRAGMATIC
AND COMPASSIONATE ANSWER THAT
DOES NOT INVOLVE TEAR GASSING
CHILDREN.
>> WE LOOK AT TEAR GASSING FOR
THAT'S THE UNITED STATES CAUSING
THAT.
>> HE WANTS THAT CHAOS ON THE
BORDER AS HE CONTINUES TO TREAT
THESE PEOPLE, SO MANY OF WHOM
ARE LEAVING VIOLENT LIVES IN
CENTRAL AMERICA, LIKE TRYS
TERRORISTS.
>> YOUR MAINSTREAM MEDIA DOING
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING TO
VILIFY PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER THE
CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
HOWEVER, AS PER USUAL, THEY HAVE
COMPLETELY FAILED TO TELL THE
WHOLE TRUTH.
LOOK AT THE STUDY TONIGHT FROM
NEWS BUSTERS.
LAST NIGHT, NETWORKS TOTALLY
IGNORED THE USE OF TEAR GAS
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
DO YOU REMEMBER THIS KIND OF HIS
TEAR YA?
TEAR GAS WAS USED ABOUT ONCE A
MONTH DURING BARACK OBAMA'S TIME
IN OFFENSE IN ORDER TO REPEL
MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER.
ONCE A MONTH.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
ISN'T THAT ALL YOU NEED TO
REALLY KNOW ABOUT THE BIAS OF
THE MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY.
THERE WAS NO MONTHLY OUTRAGE
OVER THE ACTIONS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, NO
GRANDSTANDING, NO DRAMATIC PLEAS
FOR CIVILITY, NO TALK ABOUT
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
THIS SHOWS WITHOUT ANY SHADOW OF
A DOUBT, THE DESTROY TRUMP
PRESS, AND THAT'S WHO THEY ARE,
ARE WILLING TO DO AND SAY
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING TO
DAMAGE THE ADMINISTRATION.
THIS HAS BEEN TWO YEARS AND ON
GOING.
MANY ON THE LEFT TRY TO PAINT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AS
MONSTERS.
THE STATISTICS, THE TRUTH,
HISTORY TELLS A MUCH DIFFERENT
STORY.
IN FACT, 100,000 ASYLUM CLAIMS
WERE PROCESSED LAST YEAR UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BY THE WAY, THAT HAPPENS TO BE A
RECORD-SETTING AMOUNT.
THAT'S UP 6,000 FROM OBAMA'S
FINAL YEAR IN OFFICE.
UNDER THE TRUMP IMMIGRATION
APPLICATION, INTO THE UNITED
STATES THEY HAVE SURGED.
PROBABLY BECAUSE OF THE BETTER
ECONOMY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS CAUSES
SERIOUS BAG LOGS AND WE NOW ARE
CURRENTLY AT 786,000 PENDING
IMMIGRATION CASES.
KEEP IN MIND, THE U.S. HAS
RECEIVED 160,000 ASYLUM CASES
THIS YEAR, COMPARED TO JUST
42000 IN 2008.
A GOOD ECONOMY, AGAIN.
AS OF SEPTEMBER, THERE WERE
42000 LIKELY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
HELD IN ICE DETENTION FACILITIES
DESPITE ONLY ENOUGH FUNDING AND
CAPACITY FOR 40,000 PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS REQUESTED MORE
FUNDING FOR ICE.
AS WE KNOW AND AS WE CAN SEE,
AMERICA'S IMMIGRATION RESOURCES
ARE STRETCHED EXTREMELY THIN.
THEY ARE OPERATING AT MAXIMUM
CAPACITY.
THIS MAKES THE SITUATION AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER EVEN MORE
SERIOUS AND MORE DANGEROUS FOR
THOSE PEOPLE THAT PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE TO PROTECT OUR
COUNTRY, OR SOVEREIGNTY, OUR
BORDERS, OUR RULE OF LAW.
NONE OF THIS SEEMS TO MATTER TO
THE LEFT.
THE PRESIDENT IS WORKING HARD TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF OUR
AMERICAN PEOPLE, OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM, STRENGTHEN OUR BORDERS
AND ASK PEOPLE TO RESPECT OUR
LAOS.
THE LEFT IS WORKING OVERTIME TO
DESTROY THE REPUTATION OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
NO CONSPIRACY IS TOO ABSURD, NO
LIE TOO EGREGIOUS.
I DIGRESS HERE A SECOND.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS TAKE CONTROL
OF THE HOUSE, WHEN THEY DO, WE
HAVE GREAT THINGS PLANNED.
IT IS ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE,
MARK MY WORDS.
TWO YEARS, NEVER-ENDING NONSTOP
ATTACKS, NONSTOP INVESTIGATION.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO FOR